du rire et surtout de la femme puisque
jusqu'au 25 mars
ici au carrefour socioculturel de
mondeville là où ça bouge je vous
informe que ce sera la fête de la femme
avec des expositions et surtout en point
d'orgue un formidable concert mardi 8
mars pour la journée de la femme j'ai
tout dit oui tout à fait sauf le nom
sauf les noms que je vais vous dévoiler
donc de grandes chanteuses voilà nous
vont venir souffler les bougies des 5
ans du festival avec nous diane tell
j'irai vers toi
amandine bourgeois quoi ma gueule
qu'est ce qu'elle a ma gueule jk plan de
ce qu'il sait
clarika qui n'était pas qu'il n'avait
pas encore donné sa réponse au moment de
la fiche
et puis maureen dor c'est à 20 heures au
carrefour socioculturel de mondeville on
reste
merci beaucoup en reste avec les femmes
on va aller à agneaux cette fois ci
puisque demain soir la chorale
formidable et 10 vagabonde se propose de
vous offrir un joli concert c'est à
partir de 20 heures à la salle des fêtes
d'agneau extraits et puis moi je voulais
rendre hommage jacques à une grande dame
béatrice dalle qui jouera ce soir pour
la dernière fois
lucrèce borgia d'après victor hugo mise
en scène par monsieur qu'on connaît bien
en normandie
david bobée et ce sera ce soir à
hérouville saint clair
donc ne manquez pas le i marsh ce grand
concert exceptionnel de d'énormément de
femme diane tell jil caplan amandine
bourgeois et clarika et puis aussi
n'oubliez pas le festival de pâques vous
êtes à dauphine mathieu c'est ça oui
jacques nous sommes à deauville
dans la salle les lignes d'eau brignac
ici avait les yearlings à quelques temps
qui on va entendre de la musique
classique de la grande classique ce sont
les jeunes pousses qui vont venir jouer
c'est ça oui c est ce qu on appelait le
pur-sang de la double croche qui arrive
bien deux ou trois générations de
musiciens depuis 1997 se donnent
rendez-vous aussi dans toutes les
formations de chambre le trio jusqu'au
grand orchestre symphonique
on peut le dire ici à salies du brainiac
il ya beaucoup de musiciens qui ont
commencé leur carrière rue affirmant une
centaine on ait eu 500 musiciens depuis
certains sont devenus des grandes stars
comme bertrand chamayou comment on
aurait pu son comique alors billich
david kadouch de plaies très belles
lettres
on a créé aussi lycéens or qu'est-ce qui
fait tous les opéras de mozart le cercle
de l'harmonie qui vous dire des champs
elysées part dans le monde et sont nés
ici puisque on les prend très jeune on
les prépare pendant quatre ou cinq ans
il se rend compte qu'ils se connaissent
la présente dans la carrière avec
beaucoup de temps beaucoup de concerts
derrière eux à deauville avant de
rentrer dans les grands festivals
vous êtes attaché au journal régional ah
oui oui beaucoup oui qu'est-ce que je
présente mon truc de culture elle
attendait le nom m'échappe
là où ça bouge voilà voilà voilà voilà